let's cut to the chase I wrote another
book yeah I can't believe it either
I didn't get these bags in my eyes by
shopping at the mall brilliants like
that can be found on my new book that's
right today's video is just a quick
announcement to let you guys know that
I've written a second book Grace and
style the art of pretending you have it
you see a qcf can you see yeah take it
in feel it feel anything and tell me
what that's like wow the first book I
wrote was a tongue-in-cheek self-help
book and this book is now a
tongue-in-cheek style guide fashion my
body wouldn't even allow me to continue
with that sentence you don't think I
have fashion advice and this is a fake
mock-up look there's nothing behind the
cover just like me
Grace's style the art agenda you have it
is now available for pre-sale if you go
to grace style book calm grace style
book calm I'm really excited about this
book because I would want to read this
if I didn't write it myself and that's
always a good measure
strained emotional facial expression
this is me smizing it's definitely not a
how-to dress because clearly I know far
too much around that instead it's more
of an entertaining silly look at the
world of style and fashion and beauty
and that sort of thing
and I hope that you guys go pre-order
because I think you'll find some of it
fun or funny or maybe even helpful dare
I say in the fashion world and your
personal style world grace Balcom I
don't know a ground turkey and guacamole
for breakfasts and like most of my
clothing choices great in theory in the
privacy of my own home that then leaving
the house it's dangerous